also quadrat blöcke weil gleich einen
meter mehr oder weniger als es minecraft
hier größer als die erde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft heute am dienstag wo ich eure
facts vorstelle ja es ist mittlerweile
ja schon so ein bisschen zu einem mehr
oder weniger ritual geworden dass ich
vor den folgen mal so ein bisschen sagen
was bei mir los ist und so habe ich
meinen softbox gekauft haben einer
tastatur gekauft allerdings war ich am
wochenende im fußballstadion und bin
auch heute abend wieder auf schalke weil
champions league ist und alles mögliche
und ich habe mich im stadion total
erkältet weil die shirt bei den total
kalten temperaturen und meiner nase
total zu nicht abhalten märz und meine
stimme ein bisschen heiß und ich habe so
ein bisschen glasige augen alles möglich
also bitte verzeiht es mir es tut mir
leid ich bin auf dem weg der besserung
ich habe aber wieder richtig cool effect
am start und echt ganz interessant und
echt auch verblüffende sachen heute
wieder sehen würde ich mich freuen wenn
ihr bis zum ende dran bleibt euch das
video anschauen und eventuell weitere
effekt wenn ihr welche willst per mail
an contact china.com zusendet unterwegs
sein
der erste effekt wurde mir zugesendet
von luca und zwar kennt ihr ja er heisst
auch luca und zwar kenne dass er wenn
ihr hof liegt und gefeilt von den ganz
oben runter dann sind hier ganz viele
partikel wenn ich von hierunter fallen
sind hier weniger partikel wenn ich
jetzt allerdings hoch fliege und wieder
runter also immer nur auf diese höhe von
der ich wohin runter gefallen wenn der
gesehen die partikel war relativ gering
allerdings wird in minecraft diese höhe
im multipliziert und zwar das sind immer
so fünf blöcke weiß gar nicht ob das
ganze jetzt irgendwie sieben mal gemacht
oder so fall jetzt runter jetzt müssen
die partikel ja eigentlich relativ klein
sein weil ja nur diese fünf blöcke hoch
geflogen
allerdings sind diese partikel haid
extrem an meine nase sitzung fühle ich
hab schon gesehen die partikel waren
relativ groß und die ganze werden
aufeinander agiert also die höhe also
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise eine kuh
mit ihr hier beispielsweise über wasser
mal so ein bisschen hoch fliegen wieder
so ein bisschen runter immer relativ
wenig also ihr seht schon insgesamt von
der höhe her okay es ist ein bisschen
krass hochgeflogen jedenfalls hab ich
dir jetzt mal so von höhe so ein
bisschen hoch gezogen wenn ich jetzt
nach unten ziehe da drauf hätte schon
die coups einfach direkt tot und die
partikel war extrem viel obwohl sie
quasi einfach nur immer so und an einer
höhe hoch und runter gezogen wurde ist
eine ganz interessante sache dann kann
dich luca das war völlig normales
konfekt nummer 2 der zweite effekt wurde
mir zugesandt von tim und zwar meint tim
nimm dir doch mal ein schnee- und einen
weißen teppich der trick die mit den
schnee in dem himmel beispielsweise zwei
stehen hier ein teppich und ihr seht
schon der teppich ist am kleinsten dann
kommt dieser schnee der circa doppelt so
großes und dann kommt dieser schnell
wieder doppelt so groß ist wie der also
viermal so groß wie dieser kleine
teppich allerdings ist es ganz komisch
und zwar wenig f5 drücken sieht man das
ganz gut wenn ich jetzt auf den teppich
hier drauf gehe ich schon meine füße
gehen noch auf den teppich das heißt
nicht jeder ein bisschen hoch ich denke
das sieht man ganz klar ganz klar dass
ich das ein bisschen hochgeht welcher
allerdings in den teppich gehe in den
schnee wieder so ein bisschen runter
also ich sag jetzt ein bisschen einen im
schnee und hier wenn ich dann hier drauf
bild sag ich hier auch wieder ein also
im schnee sagt man immer so ein bisschen
ein mit den füßen obwohl er quasi
eigentlich höher sogar ist halt der
teppich das ist wohl irgendwie so bei
den echten schnee sie auch so pulver und
einfach eingefroren als gefangener regen
beispielsweise wo man halt einfach
eintreten kann ich weiß jetzt schon mal
vorgestellt wie das ist mit dem schnee
dass man sich quasi auf einer stufe
darunter befindet allerdings noch nie
mit teppichen verglichen und ich denke
das ist ganz cool weil auf teppichen
kann man ganz normal laufen
als wert halt sondern so ein blog so ein
bisschen in der höhe es gab ganz kurz
gewackelt allerdings schnee muss man
immer so ein bisschen warten miteinander
drinnen und ahmad lässig und das auf
jeden fall eine ganz interessante sache
danke an dich ja freunde wer kennt es
nicht den guten alten regen minecraft
viele hassen ihnen einige mögen
und der riese ganz normal runter normal
jetzt so dass es noch mal das tempo ich
befinde mich hier gerade auf einer ganz
normalen höhe also ich fliege nicht
irgendwie rundum her also ich stehe
einfach ganz normale der luft wenn ich
hoch fliege sieht es dementsprechend
wird der schnee der regel schneller nach
unten fliegen wenn ich jetzt allerdings
nach unten fliege seht ihr schon dass
ich in nahezu gleich schnell bin mit dem
regen das sieht extrem cool aus wie
jetzt wieder hier will sie die ok blabla
so ist es wieder extrem stellen und so
bin ich wieder nahezu gleich mit dem
regen also der regel ist nur ein
stückchen schneller als man selbst
und das ist mehr oder weniger so ein
sehr unnützer fake aber allgemein alle
facts sind einfach unnützes wissen
bringt einem nicht wirklich viel
also von daher wenn man einfach runter
flick ist man nahezu genauso schnell
wieder regen
das war für etwa drei da wird mir
zugesendet von noah cooler kerl
googlemail und ich weiß freunde alle von
euch kannten diesen fake schon ihr seid
die bloss der vierte effekt wurde mir
zugesandt von michel eckardt sagte in
minecraft und zwar ich habe
herausgefunden dass wenn man pfeile
durch ein netter portal skis kommen sie
zum beispiel der normalen welt wieder
raus diesen fällen könnte man zum toll
benutzen wenn jemand vor dem portal
steht das ist echt ganz cool und zwar so
wenig schnee der noch einmal normal in
der normalen welt vor allem länder
portal und wenn ich das mal reingehen
also ihr seht ihr hier so im umkreis
hier sind keine feinde oder so als hätte
ich schon vorher welche ihn geschossen
jetzt gehen wir mal ganz kurz in letter
ich hoffe dass michael jetzt nicht an
den letter jetzt geladen wird
er geht aber noch und zwar kann ich
jetzt hier einfach mal pfeile auf das
portal darauf schießen und ihr seht
schon die gehen also ein bisschen durch
einige pfeile werdet ihr auch gleich
sehen die bleiben in dem portal stecken
in dieser wand so ein bisschen werden
dann es teleportiert ihr geht jetzt auch
hier hinter liegen auch schon ein paar
falle weil es klappt nicht mit allen
fällen also ich habe schon sechs stück
geschossen liegen jetzt beispielsweise
nur zwei stück dann kann ich hier immer
wieder hingegen schießen jetzt einfach
durch geschossen jetzt gehe ich wieder
zurück in die normale welt und ihr seht
schon hier sind pfeile hier waren vorher
nämlich keine pfeile auch auf der
rückseite sind eventuell verendet die
auf der rückseite nicht nur auf dieser
seite hierhin liegt fallen und hier sind
echte beim feierlichen geschossen worden
das heißt man kann echt wirklich nicht
nur mops durch sylt portal durch
schicken sondern auch
et cetera und das ist ein ganz coole
sache dann kann dich warten sagt michael
passend zum fünften tag der mir zu
gesammelt wurde von angelo habe ich mich
mal hier oben auf seinem punkt gestellt
wo man so ein bisschen mehr rundum
blicken kann in minecraft und zwar der
anschluss mehr geschrieben cool affekt
alle minecraft welt ist 3,6 milliarden
quadratmeter groß also quadrat blöcke
will einen blog gleich einen meter mehr
oder weniger als ist minecraft viel
größer als die erde und jeder weiß dass
die erde 510 trilliarden quadratmeter
fläche beinhaltet also quadratmeter mehr
oder weniger als abgezogen einfach so
und dementsprechend ist die mannschaft
fällt einfach schon locker irgendwie 10
50 100 200 mal so groß ich weiß gar
nicht genau ich kann das gar nicht so
gut im kopf rechnen könnt ihr mal
ausrechnen und zwar ist das einfach so
ich hatte damals immer diese van fake
sag ich mal drei fix plus einen fun fact
in den damaligen folgen und das hier ist
wirklich echt so ein richtiger fun fact
mehr oder weniger dass man einfach mal
guckt okay da ist die world baut auf der
einen seite auf der anderen der
multipliziert das dann hab ich die
quadrat blöcke beziehen also
quadratmeter mit der metallglocke und
dies und das und das fängt mit der
richtigen welt ist es halt so dass
minecraft echt viel viel größer gibt ist
und das auch einfach ganz interessant
und zwar bekomme ich immer wieder so
viele kommentare und lese die auge
folgte das minecraft new world order hat
damals war alles viel besser als das
unendlich ist und alles mögliche leute
wenn ihr in minecraft alles schon
gesehen habt jede einzelne kann jeder
einzelnen blog von eurer welt dann seid
ihr hundertprozentig schon längst tot
weil das könnt ihr bis zu ihrem tod
nicht machen das ganze ist so wie sich
alles und einfach unendlich es ist
nahezu unendliches world order was ist
nahezu unendlich man sagt ja auch die
erde ist unendlich weil man immer wieder
drum rum und alle möglichen ecken und
man wird nie alles von der erde sehen
und ja ich würde sagen das war's mit der
heutigen folge passend dazu geht gerade
auch schon die sonne unter wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich sagen bitte
einfach dann daumen hoch geben würde
mich extrem freuen weil viele leute elbe
runter geben die man auch das ist ja so
kaka unter der anlage viel besser und
wir die serie feierte mehr davon sehen
wollt einfach eine bewertung abgeben
beziehungsweise mir dann in die
kommentare schreiben wenn die bessere
von crafter gmail.com ich mache mich
jetzt wenn ich nach schalke im stadion
und anderen video widerwillig dann
hoffentlich wieder gesund bin